baggage ring like you were like oh when
they're older this package you don't
want to deal with that and it's kind of
like and you're like she's got issues
she's got life experiences and whatnot
and it's just from the perspective of
like let's accept issues of Quake
baggage
um like most of people's issues come
from like in their younger years like
their relationship with their parents
like abuse that happens with like
extreme cases abuse when they're like
younger children like just so you can
get I suppose my point is you're here
you look for a younger girl because
she's I suppose more of a clean slate
but what happens when you get like a
younger girl and she's like gone through
that sort of stuff or like has mental
health problems
definitely what I would say to that is
to think of it like this let's say even
if the case that they do experience that
at a younger age
the more time I give them
they're going to still be in the dating
pool they're still going to have other
experiences added on top of that so I
think of more I think it more of like
let me catch it at the shortest point
you know what I mean because sure you
could go through all those different
traumas whatever whatever but then I
could be that cutting point for you you
know what I mean instead of you going
into five other different relationships
to 30 other different bodies okay maybe
that's extreme but it's like
the more time I give you the more that's
going to be added on to that so it's
like let me just cut it while it's short
you know you feel me yeah yeah it's not
the same for men then as well
um because men will get more buyers the
longer they love
I don't really think you you like
originally I don't think you guys really
care about that in the sense like
because I think we have to we have
different type of baggage women love
baggage actually I don't want them on
with kids yeah that's what you would
think but but that's not true according
to the day you know felons um violent
felons reproduce more than non
non-violent felons
can I just thought that's a question
here
um correctly I feel like when the guys
are talking about baggage and then when
the women are talking about baggage I
feel like the word the definition of
that word is slightly different
two different things so yeah when you're
saying back because I feel like I
understand you but when you you're
saying baggage I feel like something
else you're talking about something else
I'm seeing kids I'm saying a lot of past
relationships I'm saying trauma that I
could step on accidentally things like
that is that the same for the rest of
you I consider that kind of baggage
maybe yeah I I don't think past I don't
personally think that men with kids is
baggage but I think women with kids a
baggage for men because you guys gotta
provide for the kid yeah after the kid
and everything I just don't think if a
man's in a certain position that you
want him to be and if he's got a kid
then I don't see that as baggage but you
can have to be a mother to someone
else's thing like yoga how is that baby
baby mama drama yeah I'm constantly
seeing a child that reminds you of their
exactly as a jealous lady thank you
I'm not saying it's the same type of
baggage but it is it is like a
responsibility that
it's not like ideal but I just think
um it's less important than that it's
worse for you guys to meet a woman that
has kids than for me to meet a man that
has kids I think
um
the mum usually looks after the kid
anyway in most cases more than the dad
you don't have to actually be a stepmom
I don't think okay wait so just so I I
just I don't want to misunderstand you
so you're saying for a man going for a
woman who has kids
it's more it's it's all baggage but it's
more of a baggage for a man entering
that situation it's more of a burden for
a man that's what I think the financial
investment information if if dads are
less involved than being a stepdad you
basically don't have to do because men
are less involved in the parenting if
you're saying that women naturally yeah
because you said that women all she's
talking about I think you're talking
about primary custody right no but like
you said the women are more likely take
off to the kids but then if you're a
stepdad you're not going to really have
to be around like you'll be around them
but you won't have too much of a dad to
them so like if you had a kid and he was
your your man like yeah
you wouldn't have to look after them
if we like live together I guess
it's just um the biggest issue that I've
I've heard um like my co-host on
Tuesdays his name's Sarah he he said
that he had he dated um a single mom for
10 years was basically that a lot of
single mothers will let you know that
you're not the dad
and so basically like if you want to
parent them one way and she wants to
parent them a different way it like
she'll always let you know that's not
your kid
I said they lose the dominance kind of
they lose that it's just I mean they
have all the responsibility of the kid
they have to make sure he's fed they
have to make sure he's taken care of
they have to make sure you know he has a
male role model all that stuff but they
they don't get
yeah the responsibility that comes with
it
but then you've got baby father drama as
well and baby fathers when it comes to
stepping on another man's ego oh they
never like okay it's uh personally like
I I think it would be wait okay I think
I think it would be hard to date a guy
with kids personally but I just don't
tell the world what to be and women tend
to go for men with kids more than
without kids like again historically it
was a sign of pre-selection like how did
Genghis Khan impregnate like half of the
world
I agree with that one to an extent to be
fair I think it's just when you have
people that have that kind of lifelong
commitment with somebody else because
that's what happens when you have a
child I think on both sides it brings a
lot of complications I think that's
right if you don't want that drama I'm
curious who here um raise your hand if
you would date someone with a kid
okay so one two three okay I have in the
past but it's not my preference it's not
your preference yeah exactly I would but
it wouldn't be my preference but as as
women well me anyway I will I would go
for a man who is around his 30s he's
more likely to have a child like it
wouldn't be my first pick but you know
if he's got all the other qualities and
stuff rather than
someone who doesn't have the qualities I
want and doesn't have a kid then
yeah I feel like it's easier to
emotionally invest and be maternal to
someone else's kids than for a man to
financially invest in someone else's
kids so you're saying it's like easier
for a woman in that sense yeah man yeah
I don't know
I think that
if you're a man and you're doing your
thing money ain't nothing but a thing
that's it yeah
it's not the case but it that's the
thing you really still shouldn't be okay
but it's not even about money a lot of
the time it's again back to the freedom
without responsibility so they have all
the responsibility of a kid but they
don't get the freedom the freedom to
parent them how they want and then on
top of that like you know she can leave
and then he'll have no rights to the
kids well yeah and that lack of Freedom
like will um kind of be reciprocating
your relationship I guess because she's
got power over something you don't but
what all of the guys have been saying is
that like they don't want to look after
somebody else's kid because it's a
burden to them they have to provide for
these kids so it is about the money then
isn't it they don't want to perform this
kid and give emotional like
um financial support to this kid like
like you just said it wasn't about the
money you said it was about I'm saying
sorry if I said it wasn't about the
money at all I misspoke I I'm just
saying it's not always just about the
money so even if a guy has money he's
still
he's like if he still has the issue that
she will remind you that it's not your
kid moms but something without the fact
of the money if if they know that you
have a kid and they're still looking for
a long-term situation then why does the
kid matter like if you know they have a
kid and you still want a long-term
situation with them then if you're not
willing to put in the effort and like
that risk take that risk that if it does
end then the kid will be out of your
life then why are you still going into
it I think I think It ultimately depends
on the baby father like how involved he
is in in all of this because between men
there's there's like an on on unspoken
codes
if if that if if yes if he's completely
out of the picture then you have a lot
more options as a man to to to do what
you've got to do
but if you have to interact with this
guy every every Friday when he comes to
pick up the kids you know what I mean
and then you look at each other you size
each other up and then he's just there
it's a lot more aggro and a hassle you
don't need it it's dangerous it's
dangerous for men because if he if he's
just come out of a 10-year stretch and
you know I mean all these kind of things
as a man you like just just a woman with
another child puts You In Harm's Way as
a man because you don't know who this
guy who she she breeded with you know I
mean I would never date someone with a
kid because I don't want to deal with
their like their emotional baggage and
like kind of be responsible for their
past decisions because that is like you
having a child was a decision and now I
have to be responsible for that decision
and it's like it's not I shouldn't have
to take that off you like I don't have
to deal with your past traumas because
they're yours they're not mine yeah
because I was saying just said adding on
to it so I'm not gonna go into like
names and stuff but like
um as Paul was saying about you know the
authority
especially from like a masculine
perspective
already taken on someone else's
child if you look at it from like a
survival perspective that child
effectively is your enemy which is why
like when Lions take over Pride they
make sure to to kill off any legacies
that was there before and they start
again
but then to to swallow that pride is one
thing but then if you you you as of like
in in the traditional sense you need to
kind of like run your house
but then if there's children here
yeah it's like if you respect the mother
her her not allowing you the authority
over that child those children are on
the same level as her so it's just like
that whole like the whole respect tree
someone in the chat said it's like
paying for another man's orgasm
exactly you said they're fully developed
by three and if you meet her and she's
got a five-year-old that kid knows
you're not their their dad like they're
gonna it depends I mean it depends how
it runs out the the main thing yeah the
main thing I'm trying to get across
right is the fact that like all of these
things yeah it just it's very case
specific but generally speaking
from a male perspective there's just so
many factors that you have to swallow
and ignore and just try and ride with it
it's not your mind today I've slept with
someone every day seeing that kid like
it's not speak speaking from experience
like I've got my parents split when I
was very young and yeah and my mum got
had a new man from early so I grew up
with another man in the household and I
didn't like him at all like we
constantly clashed heads I was very much
like always on my dad's side I was
always looking at it like
why are you with him and not my dad
sorry for him it must have been horrible
yeah even in a household where you know
that this kid doesn't like you but if
they can if they can get over that
insecurity of the fact that there's
another man that like like father that
their their girlfriend or wife say child
then like I just don't see what the
problem is like what you were saying
about like how they have to like see
this other man if he's still in like the
picture and it's not easy to get it just
sounds like it's like that stems from
their insecurity like if you're too
insecure about the fact that the goal
you're seeing has had another like baby
in the past then like don't see her like
why is that her why is like you making
like her issue that is your problem it's
like meeting someone's ex every Friday
like meeting their ex like if you don't
like anything isn't it I just understand
it if you don't like it don't get into
the relationships
yeah but we're just explaining like why
men don't yeah
I'll agree with that even further
actually because my mum was alone for a
very long time because my dad passed
away when we were 12. and I remember
when I was 15 14 15 even 16 any man that
ever got close to my mom oh the four of
us because we're four girls we used to
give him hell because we had a certain
possession over our mom and with kids we
didn't know a lot of the time we were
younger we had a possession of our mum
and we also have loyalty to our dad yeah
okay and okay fine fair enough yeah my
dad passed away and there's a difference
but actually I find that to be the case
with a lot of people especially if the
children have got a good relationship
with the father it feels like a betrayal
yeah it's a betrayal so I think that
when you bring that kind of situation to
your life you have to understand that
there's so many elements now that you've
added to your life they have absolutely
no control over absolutely no control it
can be absolutely chaos or you can go
well a lot of the time it may not go
well in the society that we live in now
I would say if you're like maybe in
Africa or another in other continents
where life is a bit more difficult than
you actually have a bit more generous
through struggle maybe but even still I
would just say keep it clean keep it
simple keep it straight and easy it's
such a complex situation to walk into so
like generally speaking men will just be
like you know what if I got the choice
to go for a woman without kids and women
with kids
yeah because I think just just to just
to add on Twitter saying like Journey
speaking generally speaking most
children kind of have like a maternal
yearning so like if you're like say your
your father were just children you could
have sisters aunties mothers and stuff
they sort of like represent the body of
a mother in a way but then with the
father's side of things you kind of have
need that sort of like one reference
point
generally speaking but then if if you
are given the authority over the child
to raise that child as your own as a man
then that child's father has effectively
lost his child that creates a new
Dynamic that just within the male
Spectrum it's just so many moving pieces
I think for it to work for it to work
the biological data would have to be
completely out of the situation
completely yeah it's not inclined and
accepts you calling his child Dad yeah
and because I've seen it with a friend
like if she
um you know he he had a situation and
his baby mother or the mother of his
child had a new guy he was very
traditional he's like this is my house
all the children call me dead
it's also um women tend to leave
relationships more than men so it's like
Why didn't it work out with the baby
father woman leave 70 to 80 percent of
the time 90 of their college educated if
she left the father of her kids she
might leave you too men value loyalty as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible